please welcome brian nikki bella
i love them good day
ladies i'm so excited to be hanging out
with you guys
oh my gosh every time i see you too like
the mom and me who is like
afraid of bone breakage just looks at
how you guys hurl yourselves
around with your bravery and bravado
and now you are moms with your beautiful
children born
a day apart which just means the
universe wants to keep you two together
right in every capacity and we're just
such big fans of yours
and i'm so excited for your new season
and your incredible new york times
bestseller hey ladies
to hit the stores in paperback tomorrow
all right you want to do the news with
us
i need letters let's do it all right
we're pop culture junkies over here
okay are you guys ready we got it i've
been oh my god
this is the biggest ladies i know you
and i know you're going to be obsessed
with this as well did you hear the news
drew huge news from sarah jessica parker
last night on instagram
sjp confirmed that sex in the city is
coming back okay
oh my gosh 20 21
it's already so good okay are you ladies
sorry there's streamers all over me
how excited were you when you heard this
news um beyond we have been obsessed
with sex in the city forever and nikki
and i both feel like there still
hasn't been a show to take that place of
sex in the city so the facts are coming
back i'm like give me it all
i can't wait to see where the women are
gonna be in their lives we're just
uh love i was literally nursing mateo um
because we're over on pacific standard
time and i saw
training worldwide and i was like am i
just really tired or is this true
like it's really coming it's like
the gift we all needed it's the hope on
the horizon
and i grew up in so many different
evolutions as a
girl woman mom into this show
and they're really you're so right you
guys there has not been
anything comparable no there hasn't and
this just means that they have been
getting my letters
all right prayer works finally they're
coming back the second movie did not
give me what i needed
if you know what i i miss
my friends i cannot wait to see them
thank you thank you
thank you well next up guess what
biggest sports junkie ever to the queens
of bravery and bravado
and can-doism and the biggest i mean you
really you guys
put wrestling on the map in ways i i and
growing up in the world like you embody
you know
you are the example and so it's time for
sports oh
well yeah that's my segment drew it's
time for sports sports sports
[Music]
i'm the one with the whistle all right
by the way you finally got a good
whistle
this is a great whistle and ladies you
know me you know i i love sex in the
city and i love
football so i spent this whole weekend i
did binge four episodes of bridgeton
thanks to drew we'll talk about it later
but i also watched all the nfl playoff
games
and the washington post says the browns
they for the first time since like 1995
they won a playoff game who saw it
coming they beat the steelers 48 to 37.
my seahawks lost which moment of silence
please
thank you so much uh they you know the
browns one i wore the color for the
browns this orange color because their
helmets are orange even though they're
called the browns which
i know i never understood uh but they
won this game without their head coach
and they advanced to the playoffs
they're they're uh going to play the
kansas city chiefs did you watch
football this weekend ladies
oh i did and i will say this i was blown
away by by the grounds because
they have been awful for a very long
time yeah but i am rooting for the
chiefs because we're philadelphia eagle
girls and angie reed their head coach
used to be our head coach
and he just he owns my heart so
i know they won last year but i'm going
for the chiefs this year
well i'm officially all in for the
browns because i like an underdog thank
you
i just have to say between sex and the
city and football i feel like it spans
the gamut
of what we all live for we want to
have sisterhood and brotherhood and
everything in between
and we want to watch people do
extraordinary things and that's why i
was so excited to talk to you guys today
thank you so much for being on the show
because i've spent years watching you do
the impossible
and you're just such heroes of ours and
thank you so much for doing the news
with us today
and don't forget everybody new york
times bestseller comes out in paperback
tomorrow total bell is thursday at 9pm
on e premiering this thursday and
thank you you guys are so awesome
[Music]